By most recent scandaries, I'll show it for a colorectal cancer going from stage 3,
T3 to T4A to tumor penetration, penetrating the visceral pair to the end.
I understand there's a risk of perforation, but not sure how significant.
I talked to a radiation oncologist. He says a low risk with certain
current circumstances and oncologists makes it sound even more serious.
Seems to throw a wrench into some plants for metabolic treatment.
So this person was considering going a full metabolic,
both going on a ketogenic type diet,
and funnel things back in the direction of allopathic treatment,
perhaps awkward to come in, but welcome any thoughts anyway.
Yeah, I think it's hard to, it's always difficult to know what to do.
Should I do chemotherapy and radiation?
Is it the right time to add that to my protocol?
It's such a difficult thing to combat time.
But certainly if the cancer is not going in a direction that we want
to be going at everything that you're doing, you've got to consider other things.
But doing a metabolic approach, that's your decision that we talked about before.
You're changing up your treatment.
It's not like, I mean, I don't think your oncologist is saying,
you've got to do something right now. You've got to make a decision
in the next couple of weeks. We've got to move ahead with this.
You still have time to try something else. I mean, if it was me, I think I would
switch up my treatment the way we've been talking about and try this and see if that
makes a difference within three months. Then you know,
set yourself some parameters that, okay, I'm going to try this and make this change
for three months. And if there's, if I feel better and you know with
my scans are not progressing in the wrong direction,
then I'm going to continue on with that. So I think you still have time to
try some different things. So that's what I would suggest.